[Musik]
bild breaking news
atemlos in dieses bild live spezial mit
einer exklusiven nachricht sie ist der
deutsche superstar helene fischer 16
millionen verkaufte tonträger 17 echos
zwei goldene kameras immer wieder
atemlos an die spitze der charts und
bald ganz bald da heißt es für helene
atemlos in den kreißsaal denn helene
fischer ist schwanger und das halt bild
exklusiv erfahren
[Musik]
helene fischer sie ist der superstar
unter den super-stars megaerfolgreich
mega sexy und bald eine mega mama die
schlager queen macht mit ihrem
spektakulären bühnenshows seit jahren
die größten arenen in deutschland voll
tausende fans beten sie an und helene
bricht in den offiziellen deutschen
charts einen rekord nach dem nächsten
[Musik]
atemlos durch die nacht ist in
deutschland das am häufigsten
heruntergeladene lied aller zeiten mit
rund einer million downloads
2004 schickt fischers mutter eine demo
cd an den künstler manager uwe kanthak
dann der große durch es folgen
bühnenauftritte plattenverträge tourneen
und 2014 die beziehung zu polen silber
14 jahre später die trennung und eine
neue liebe bei helene luftakrobaten
thomas seite nach monatelanger pause
kehrt helene fischer nächstes jahr bei
einem xxl konzert zurück auf die bühne
zu dabei dann aber nicht nur als
superstar sondern auch als super mama
und recherchiert hat diese exklusive
nachricht unsere stellvertretende
chefredakteurin tanja may tanja was für
eine nachricht es ist das baby auf das
ganz deutschland wartet helene fischer
ist spange wissen wir denn irgendwas in
welchem monat zwischen ist also mir
wurde gesagt dass er lehne bereits im
vierten monat ist und dass es ihr sehr
gut geht und ja sie kann reisen und sie
kann sich natürlich auch vorbereiten auf
all das was jetzt kommt am 15 oktober
erscheint ja ihr album und wir haben
auch exklusiv erfahren dass sie am 6
november bei wetten dass auf dem sofa
sitzen wird und ich vermute mal dass sie
dann über dieses wunsch baby sprechen
wird viele viele informationen wir
probieren das mann zuordnen also vierter
monat ist sie schwanger das heißt das
baby wird kommen im februar märz mit dem
baby kommen und das ist eigentlich der
perfekte zeitplan weil sie hat dann
genügend zeit kann sich vorbereiten auf
das konzert was sie im april haben wird
ja dann in österreich das ist das erste
konzert und dann kommt ja das
megakonzert im august
450.000 menschen in münchen und da wird
sie natürlich fit sein wie immer wird
uns alle begeistern und wird
wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen mehr
strahlen weil dann ist sie eben was
wissen wir denn war das ein wunsch baby
ist das baby so gekommen was was wissen
wir darüber na ja ich kenne ihn ja seit
vielen jahren und sie hat auch nie ein
geheimnis daraus gemacht sie wollte
immer mama sein als auch als sie mit
florian silbereisen zusammen war auf der
bühne stand in ihren konzerten sie hat
immer erzählt wie sehr die kinder liebt
sie ist ja auch patentante sie hat auch
songs für ihre patenkinder geschrieben
und es war immer so auf der bühne was da
auch immer so eine träne floss vor
rührung wenn sie über die kinder
gesungen hat wenn sie gesprochen hat und
ich weiß 2017 stand sie auf der bühne in
münchen und hat gesagt eines tages werde
ich selbst mama sein ja und deswegen ich
freue mich riesig für helene muss ich
sagen weil es ist ihr großer traum der
in erfüllung geht beruflich hat sie
alles erreicht was geht und jetzt kommt
eben die familie dran tolle tolle
nachricht großartige nachricht ich
folgte vor allem wenn du sagst du hast
sie mit kindern erlebt wie wie war sie
mit kindern ist es ihnen familienmensch
sie ist ein absoluter familienmensch als
ihre eltern ihre schwester und auch als
mit florian zusammen weil es ja auch ein
familienmensch und jetzt eben der thomas
eickel ihr neuer lebensgefährte auch ein
familienmensch und man weiß er hoffte
auf ihren konzerten oder auch in ihrer
zdf weihnachtsshow da sind immer kinder
eingeladen sie singt mit den kindern sie
schmust mit den kindern und man merkt
einfach sie fühlt sich wohl wenn sie mit
kindern zusammen ist jetzt hast du
gerade den papa angesprochen der papa
kommt ja wieso nachrichten sowieso immer
viel zu kurz aber sagt uns einmal mehr
ist der papa ja der papa ist der thomas
eickel mit dem ist elena seit 2008 10
zusammen die haben sich verliebt bei der
arbeit er ist ja einer der besten
luftakrobaten also strapaten akrobat der
welt und die beiden haben sich verliebt
werden der mega tournee von helene
fischer
[Musik]